susannah is with us in Florida hi
Susanna how are you how are you better
than I deserve how can I help
um well I have a lot of bit and I was
wondering if I should chapter seven
think with me or not how much debt have
you got um total is two hundred and
fifty nine thousand dollars that
includes my mortgage how much of that is
your mortgage a hundred and forty eight
thousand and what is the other hundred
and ten
I have seventy-eight thousand and cars
and thirty-three in like loans credit
cards and medical bills
what's your house worth um about 175 and
what's your household income about a
hundred and six hundred and sixty
thousand a year but after taxes is told
us up to about um about 87 to 90 how
long you been married and you handle all
the money without his looking at it yeah
yeah so you're pretty scared yeah Barry
does he know where everything is
yes he knows how bad this is well the
great news is you're not bankrupt not
even close
you're scared because you're
disorganized and you're behind and you
don't know what to do next and you don't
have a plan and so you're overwhelmed
but you're not bankrupt did you say you
make a hundred and sixty thousand
dollars a year yeah and then at the
taxes and support it's about eighty
seven ninety a year no he didn't have
child support that's seventy thousand
dollars a year how much
child support paid 120 dollars a month
yeah okay that's more like it that's
$8,000 a year so that does not describe
from 160 to 90 what else have you got
coming out of this check pre tail like
health insurance yeah one day okay how
big was your tax refund
yeah we're expecting 11,000 yeah there's
part of it that means you're having them
take to $1,000 a month too much out of
your check that's part of it so your
take-home pay if you stopped your 401k
even with the child support coming out
and you adjust your w-4 is if you're
making 160 should be about 135 or 140
and I think that's where you're gonna
land after you make some intelligent
adjustments to this check and then we've
got all kinds of money to clean this
mess up with I would sell a couple of
cars you get you guys are car nuts yeah
that was our biggest issue yeah that was
just like that's like over in the crazy
column right there
yeah they got to go both of them and
don't tell me you wanna file bankruptcy
to keep these cars because you can't
keep them if you file bankruptcy unless
you keep the debt so these cars these
cars are stupid land I wanted to get rid
of the cars and just keep my house yeah
they can keep your house I think you
keep your house and you sell your cars
get you a couple gets you to $2,000 cars
to drive roll up your sleeves and get on
a tight budget cut get your w-2 change
to where you take home a thousand
dollars more a month
stop your 401k we're gonna get you on a
detailed written budget and the great
news is other than your house you're
gonna be dead free in about 18 months
does that sound good
I'm gonna show you how to do it if
you'll stay with me
hold on Madison's gonna pick up I'm
gonna put you in the Financial Peace
University you can turn this thing
around
and oh by the way he's gonna help you
instead of standing on the sidelines
watching you carry all this weight by
yourself